[Music]
hey step out get out get out get out
hey they're saying he's at the mall he's
still in the store what name is thor
he's at casanova right now
no yeah yeah get him out get him up
is he shooting right now
where's the cat where's the sword at if
you go in and you make a right it's
called casanova's right there on the
left walls
they're saying that he went that way
black male he has on a black bandana
and he has on a blue trench coast
there's gonna be a short black male with
the blue bandanna on the head black
black the blue trench coast black bend
and the blue trench floor
what is he riding right now
uh they said that he ran that way he has
on white pants and some red like stacy
adams okay i just need somebody to come
with me so i can't just go in by
yourself
[Music]
we went in there because hey i'm at the
front door just come i need somebody to
come with me at the front door
we got call because he was disruptive
i'm at the main entrance right now
we got called he was disrupting in the
store so when we went over there whose
gun did he have the officers which
officers all right 300 units
the security officer no our off-duty
officer
where is he at the trail he's most
likely dead he fired over eight shots at
the officer at the officer yes where at
in casa nova i just said
[Music]
where's casanova where's casanova
where's casanova at uh straight to the
right hey they're saying the officers
are shot so i'm gonna check on him right
now where's where's cassanova
where's casanova
i'm just gonna go check on the officer
where's that where's the officer at i
don't know
is the guy still in there
where is that
[Music]
[Applause]
hey whoever is coming here come to
casanova casanova
[Applause]
[Music]
is upstairs
[Applause]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
i have the suspect right in front of me
get out of the ground up to your head
let me see your head
[Music]
[Applause]
drop the knife
becca
[Applause]
no no hey what
no no no hold up
hey we need someone to go to casanova
hey i'm gonna go to casanova check on
the officers right now